Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you, Ruffians!
What did you just say?
Thank you.
No, after that.
Ruffians.
Okay, I heard Ruffians.
No!
Ruffians!
It's FUWAMOCO Morning's 30th episode!
Yeah!
Thank you for starting your day, your week, off with us again today.
I guess it's not the month, but not the month.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
For Ruffians joining us for the very first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held
Every Friday, Wednesday, Monday.
FUWAMOCO.
Yeah.
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag, hashtag, FWMCMORNING.
Yeah!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Wow!
Start off our morning with doing howls!
We have a Ruffian spot peril.
A peril sighting?
Huh?
De-den!
Oh!
Went to the arcade?
Oh, a Ruffian went to the arcade with them!
Interesting!
Pero was sculpted onto... Ruffians!
Wait, what kind of shady arcade did you end up going to, huh?
Uh, yeah... Kinda sounds a bit suspicious to me, too...
It's a good thing you went with friends.
You saved their numbers, right?
We hope you had a good time and nothing weird happened.
Nothing weird, right?
You just had a good time, beat up your friends a bit.
In video games, right?
Actually...
Ruffians, have you ever accidentally come across a cool looking arcade randomly before and went in to kind of see, check it out, you know, what kind of forgotten items they might have?
Sometimes, you know, there's some really cool retro games, maybe a lot of, I don't know.
Right!
You know what?
I like those arcades.
They're really mysterious.
So mysterious it's a bit scary.
You like the scary ones?
I don't know.
You never know what's gonna happen.
Even if they're smoky and dark and sometimes there's hidden hallways that lead to back rooms with more games.
Wow, Ruffians.
Please be cautious, okay?
Yeah, yeah, okay.
Especially if they have funny tokens of peril on them.
Uh-uh.
Yeah.
That seems dangerous.
BAU BAU!
Thank you.
Wow, there's been some pretty exciting news recently.
Did you catch it?
Ruffians.
Ruffians, I'm not saying Ruffians.
Importantly.
Yesterday, I was doing Council vs 3D showcase and something very exciting was announced!
Council and IRyS-senpai are now officially a new group together!
He's so right!
All five of them are now named hololive English -Promise-!
Were you surprised, Ruffians?
We're really happy for them.
And it's so cute!
We wish them all the best with their new beginnings, right?
They should be filled with many, many new adventures.
If you weren't able to check out the special 3D collab, we highly recommend it.
The games are really fun, but we're really surprised that Kronii-senpai, Fauna-senpai, Mumei-senpai started saying Doki Doki Morning together.
What a great start to a new chapter!
Welcome, hololive promise!
Very special day.
Wow, Ruffians.
There's something we'd also like to share.
Something we'd like to take you about.
FUWAMOCO has an original introduction song, right?
Right!
Lifetime Showtime!
Ruffians, thank you so much for 200,000 views!
Since yesterday we hit 200,000!
Thank you so much for listening to it and loving it lots and lots and lots.
We're so thankful.
It really does mean a lot to us.
It's our first little original song, so it's really special.
We didn't think it'd reach 200,000 views so fast, ever.
Maybe.
Maybe Ruffians are just very passionate.
You know, back when we said that we'd like it to reach 300,000 views one day, we were thinking, like, maybe one or two years from now, you know?
But we're very, very happy.
If you want, we can reach that sooner.
Alright, I guess.
It doesn't have to be in two years from now.
Yeah.
But, you know, we want a lot of Ruffians, hololive fans, and maybe, like, complete VTuber newbies to be able to listen to it.
And then maybe we can get a better idea as to who we are.
So it makes us really happy, you know?
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
It makes us really excited for our next original too, right?
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Please continue to enjoy listening to it, okay?
The show can't stop!
Thank you Mumei!
Wow, back to some more exciting things.
More music news!
More music news, I guess that's true.
Mumei-senpai has some pretty exciting things going on today.
First of all, at 8pm PT, Mumei-senpai will be continuing on with Part 2 of the Birthday Karaoke.
And guess what?
Ruffians.
Not only the guests, but shortly after at 9.30pm PT, she'll be premiering her new original song!
It's so cool.
Right?
We were already really excited for it when we heard that Mamei-senpai would be having a new song come out.
But after seeing the thumbnail here, we really can't wait.
What do you think it'll be like, Ruffians?
I'm really... I feel... I feel I don't know.
It could be like an emotional song about Mumei-senpai's journey.
But... I feel like... Deathcore?
Why?
I feel like it might be a bit spooky too.
It could be either.
An aria!
Emotional.
Emotional and spooky.
Deathcore.
There's a lot of deathcore there, Moco-chan.
I'm excited.
No matter what, I'm excited.
Right, right.
Let's look forward to tonight at 9.30pm.
That's like only 12 hours plus a little bit.
12 hours plus a little bit.
Very close.
Very, very close.
Okay.
I'm excited.
BAU BAU!
I don't want to think too much about this next part because Ruffians, I was starting to gain a little confidence that maybe FUWAMOCO that we've grown.
You know that there wasn't really any misunderstandings being created anymore, but again,
There's something that we need to clear up with you.
It's very important.
Yeah.
Doing our Rock n' Rawr Party the other day, you know?
I was talking about how we had lots of copies of this one CD, right?
Right?
We didn't really know the reason, but because of that, you know, we could just... We could give the Ruffians a copy or two!
But, Moco-chan... Somehow, you misheard this.
I think it was completely justified, okay?
Right, Ruffians?
If you listen back to it, you can...
Understand.
It all makes sense that I misheard what I did, okay?
I don't think so.
I'm innocent.
No.
Ruffians.
You know what Moco-chan heard?
She heard puppies, not copies.
Different copies of the CD.
You know, and considering the next song coming up, I was just a bit concerned that things were getting a bit sillier than I expected.
But I was wrong.
I just misheard.
No, puppies are for sharing.
Puppies are for keeping.
Keeping, yeah.
Nothing, nothing seems at all.
No.
Copies, not puppies.
Yeah, right?
I can have a lot of CD copies.
No.
Puppies are for keeping.
Not sharing with the Ruffians.
I have a feeling that the Ruffians have not understood the misunderstanding yet.
Puppies.
Sounds like copies.
Say it.
Puppies.
Copies.
It sounds very similar.
I don't think so.
You're only hearing puppies.
Copies.
Copies of a CD.
Not puppies of a CD.
Different.
So.
I'm good now, Ruffians?
You can't copy a puppy.
You can't.
Uh-uh.
Not coffee!
Puppies and poppies and not coffee.
You understand now, right?
We have to make sure you understand.
Say it.
Coffee, no, no.
Okay, Moco-chan, let's just move on.
Say it, Ruffians!
You understand now!
These Ruffians are a bit more cooperative, huh?
Right!
Are you going through a rebellious phase, huh?
You understand.
I've made it clear.
Puppy coffee.
Puppies and coffee.
The Ruffians are too silly and rebellious.
Next!
BAU BAU.
They understand now.
They understand.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Well... Actually, we also... We have an apology to make.
But not to the Ruffians!
No!
Right?
No, they're going through a rebellious phase.
We don't need to... They need to apologize to us.
Yeah, right.
Well... This apology is actually for... Senpai.
You know, I was looking through my notepad and I noticed something weird.
You know, I noticed that I scribbled down Respond to Ali-senpai's DM a while ago.
And I was really confused.
Because it turns out I read it while I was half asleep and then I didn't respond.
And then half asleep I wrote the task down and then I totally forgot.
Why?
How could I?
I didn't know about it.
Moco-chan never said anything to me.
I was really confused.
I was like, what DM?
Pretty awful, Moco-chan.
More awful.
You know, though, I apologize a lot.
I apologize profusely, okay?
But... Oe-senpai!
Oe-senpai, I apologize profusely now, okay?
You get it, right?
Right?
Right!
But you know, Ruffians.
You know.
It wasn't even a couple days that I didn't respond.
Do you know how long it was until I noticed?
Oh, in case you want to see, here's proof.
You know how many days I didn't respond to it for?
It was bad Ruffian.
Moco-chan see it.
It was over a week.
We're weak Ruffians.
A whole week.
That's awful.
No, I was just really confused when I saw my notes, okay?
I panicked.
Yeah.
We're sorry.
Senpai.
Did you just say we're sorry?
Oh, senpai.
We're sorry.
It won't happen again.
Right here.
BAU BAU!
How do I make you up for it?
I'm very, very sorry, Aoi-senpai!
Moco-chan, are you gonna show Aoi-senpai how amazing you are at Apex?
Are you gonna sacrifice me?
Show your big sister off!
Yeah.
Yeah, right?
Apex is her love language?
I've heard that.
What are you doing with the love language?
Apex.
We're sorry.
Mata!
BAU BAU!
Apology accepted.
You can't say that yourself, Moco-chan.
I'm speaking for all of you, FUWAMOCO.
Apology accepted.
And that's it!
Doggie of the Day!
No, no, no, no, Moco-chan.
It's the beginning of the week, you know.
Right.
And that means that Moco-chan is going to show how strong of a demon dog she is, right?
You're gonna challenge something that you've been challenging for a little while now.
You know.
BAU!
I feel like this is something Moco-chan, you can overcome.
It's something I want to do.
It's something you want to do.
The Ruffians need to know I'm just an assistant here.
Moco-chan wants to do this on her own, right?
It's something difficult and Moco-chan's going to overcome it.
I'm sure the Ruffians understand though.
There's things that you want to do, and want to get done, and get better at.
But then, when it comes to the day to do it, you can do it another day.
No!
Today's the day because Moco-chan's going to be eating natto!
Once more.
She hasn't eaten it really yet.
This is Moco-chan's first time trying to eat it on FUWAMOCO Morning.
I do want to eat it!
It's just, right now is maybe not the best time.
Maybe tomorrow is better.
Today is the day, Moco-chan.
Maybe for some Ruffians, artichoke natto is natto.
It's a common breakfast food in Japan.
It's made of fermented soybeans.
It can be rather slimy and sticky and smelly.
But it's really, really, really, really, really healthy for you.
SSS.
Not Shiny Smiley.
Story.
Sticky, slimy, smelly.
Natto.
It's really healthy for you!
I didn't know!
Moco-chan.
If you conquer your dislike, you'll be able to... Ah, your dislike of natto.
You'll be able to protect the Ruffians for a long time.
I'll be stronger.
I do... I do wanna eat it.
It's just... I have to get used to it, but I would like to not get used to it today.
Nope.
Today's the day.
Oh!
Moco-chan!
It's like... Are you feeling confident?
Not at all.
Not at all?
Like... Compared to before, what would you say?
Ten percent.
Ten percent?
I feel like...
My taste buds are not gonna accept it.
10% is 10% and today, Moco-chan, you're finally going to eat natto properly.
You're gonna eat it.
Not just put it in your mouth, okay?
Yeah.
Moco-chan, listen, listen.
If you start having doubts, think of how Poruru-oneechan would be so proud of you, right?
Right?
She will be.
Can you not stir it up though, please?
No, no, I need to do this.
You will at least have my chopsticks.
I do.
I got your- I don't want to stir it up!
Okay, but you promised tea today.
Ah.
You have to properly eat it, okay.
Stir, stir, stir, stir, stir, stir, stir.
Okay.
I always have this issue.
Can you please clean off the chopsticks?
No.
They're clean.
No, but... Here, here, here, here.
You stirred it up and now it's not good.
It's all good now.
No, it's not.
Can I have tea to start, please?
And I have tissues!
Okay.
Tea.
Quickly!
Quickly, Moco-chan!
Time!
What are you doing?
I'm going to shake it around my mouth.
Okay, Moco-chan.
First, it's important to do this.
Let's say thank you to the farmers in Tochigi.
Thank you!
I'll do my best, but I'm sorry if I can't.
Okay, Moco-chan.
Itadakimasu.
Why is it... You gotta eat it this time.
It has to reach your tummy, okay?
That's one bean.
I am doing one bean, okay?
I haven't been able to do two or three.
I do the tummy, okay?
Ruffians, is one enough?
One is enough for today, right?
One is nothing.
That's like eating a piece of salt.
What?
No, it's not.
It's nothing.
This is a bean.
Think of it as like a... I don't know.
What do you mean, no?
A raspberry.
Chuu, right?
Chuu.
Okay.
What are you doing with that thing?
I'm placing it on the corner, okay?
Moco-chan.
It's better.
It's better?
It's better this way!
Don't question, just accept, okay?
I don't know what she's doing.
I'm putting knives in the beans, okay?
I don't think I can do two!
Don't sneeze while I'm attempting my challenge, okay?
Okay Moco-chan, you ready?
They look... Don't they look so yummy?
They look very sticky today.
It's not as smelly as last time though.
Ruffians, I know we talked about it earlier, but...
She's gonna try to get out of this.
If I... If I... If I eat a bean, can I go to sleep?
What?
Can I go to sleep if I eat a bean?
No!
No way!
Ruffians say no!
Can I?
Sure.
Two beans in the sleep... I get to sleep after one bean, okay?
Two beans, Moco-chan.
Just one.
Chuu.
The Ruffians say yes.
Chuu in the tummy.
Chuu's a good number.
Into the tummy.
Yes.
Starts with a T. Tummy starts with T. Right.
No, no Chuu.
No Chuu.
I've seen too many Chuu's!
It's Chuu today.
Chuu is the number today, Moco-chan.
Okay, she has Chuu!
I'm gonna put it in my mouth and then I can go to sleep.
No, you have to eat it, Moco-chan.
Okay.
What is that?
Unhappy door opens.
Don't just look at it.
I'm staring it down.
It looks very slimy.
It's not.
It's healthy.
Okay, last time the problem was I left it in my mouth for too long.
Moco-chan, we're running out of time!
I know, it wafted.
It wafted and my tummy's not ready for it.
I'm putting this down.
She has two beans still.
Eat it quickly, would you like that?
Go ahead, eat it quickly.
Make sure you enjoy the flavor though, okay?
Thank you, Tochigi Farmers.
Okay, here we go!
Five!
Four!
No, no, no, ten, ten, ten, ten, ten.
Ten!
Nine!
Eight!
No, no, no, slow, slow, slow, slow, slow.
Ten!
Nine!
Eight!
Seven!
Six!
Five!
Four.
Three.
Two.
One!
Moco-chan.
It's one.
It's zero.
You're out of time!
Okay.
Willpower!
To the tummy!
Okay.
Willpower!
Yeah!
Natto!
Moco-chan, go for it, go for it!
You can do it!
Don't cry!
Moco-chan's making a face like a normal.
What?
Tell me, tell me, tell me, tell me, tell me, tell me, tell me.
That didn't work.
It's just that, Moco-chan.
Moco-chan.
Moco-chan, here's the tea.
Why are you passing me a natto?
You didn't eat it.
It's been in your mouth.
Eat it from the napkin.
I'm not gonna eat the natto.
It touched my tongue.
It's supposed to touch your tummy.
You touched the main part of my tongue with all the taste buds.
Natto's supposed to touch the tummy.
Well, Ruffians, I guess that was another attempt to quit our... Let's remember though... Let's remember, Ruffians, this was Moco-chan's best attempt today to eat the natto.
Yeah, and let's do...
You can't tell me no sleep.
I get to sleep.
But, Ruffians, let's use Moco-chan's attempt just now to power ourselves through all the hard things we may have to face this week.
It better.
That's a threat.
BAU BAU!
I want to be able to eat natto.
You do?
I'm not forcing you.
I'm doing my best.
You better do your best too, Ruffians, okay?
It's a threat.
BAU BAU!
Well, let's go to our regular corners that Moco-chan just wanted to jump right through to.
And I can understand because I have a feeling today's Doggie of the Day might be cute.
De-den!
We have two doggies of the day today!
Samson and Sassofrass!
Sassofrass!
I don't know Moco-chan, they're kind of like us, right?
Are they?
Don't you think, Ruffians?
I'm Sassafras.
Are you sure you're not Sassafras?
You're Samson.
I think I'm Sassafras.
No, I'm Samson.
You're Samson.
But they're not twins, though.
They're not twins.
They're half-siblings, so a little bit different.
I don't know, when I see all the wrinkles, I want to just take my finger and sort of unwrinkle the forehead wrinkles.
In a cute way.
Goodbye wrinkles.
Goodbye, goodbye, goodbye.
Thank you.
And Moco-chan, they're good at begging too.
Right, but Ruffians as demon dogs, you know.
We kinda, we have pride.
We have pride enough not to stoop to those levels.
Yeah.
Not unless we really need to, you know.
But I think if I need to, I can convince you with my puppy dog eye begging skills.
Right!
Are you gonna show us, Moco-chan?
No, not right now.
Yeah.
Well, how do they BAU BAU?
Maybe like... You know, sometimes when Moco-chan, you get kind of worked up over something, then...
You start BAU BAUing, I start BAU BAUing.
Oh, like when we cry.
Yeah, like when we cry, right?
You know it never ends, like... Alright, like that.
But you know what?
I can tell.
I can tell from this photo that Samus and Sassafras are a bit of a handful.
I mean, look at those eyes!
They're so fit!
They're cute.
They're cute, you know?
But they demand.
They demand.
And they're cute!
Yeah!
And in return, they love.
They're very cute!
BAU BAU BAU!
Wow, you know now it's getting a bit cold outside.
But yet Ruffians are still going out for walks!
Good, good.
Why did this Ruffian go for a walk this time?
De-den!
You found an old watermill along a nature trail!
Can we say it together, Moco-chan?
Resident Evil 4 Remake, right?
But, I don't know, like, it's not really like that it's scary or creepy or that zombies are going to really pop out.
But, you know, it's just somehow RE4 Remake has really beautiful environments.
It feels like a good autumn walk, right?
And that's why it kind of reminds us of it, maybe?
Yeah, but hopefully it's just a nice walk and there's no grandma or grandpa zombies that pop out at you.
No!
Safety.
BAU BAU!
Please be safe, look out for zombies.
We got a Question of the Day from a Ruffian.
Let's see.
De-den!
Good morning to my favorite doggos!
Good morning!
I'm taking two grades of Aiken.
The English proficiency test is tomorrow.
So maybe you've already taken it by now.
Satsumeshi karakushi.
Oh, what a weird test.
These tests are important, especially this kind of test, right?
These tests will quite literally decide my future.
My question is, have you guys gotten anxious about a test?
If so, how did you deal with it?
It's a good question.
We hope that your A-game went well and smoothly!
We hope you weren't too nervous about it either, but we understand what it's kind of like to have tests that are super important like that too.
We've had experiences where we're really nervous about tests a lot.
Actually, there was one class that we had as a part of our guard dog training and it was really rough.
It wasn't going well.
At all.
But we were studying really really hard the whole time and we studied really hard for the exam.
The final exam.
But it just wasn't making any sense.
We were just really exhausted.
Right before the exam, we were kind of debating whether we should just give up, stop right there, and just turn back home.
You know that it may just be a bit easier if we didn't go to the exam, just fail the final, fail the class, you know?
Because even if we did go to the final, we'd still most likely fail.
But in the end, Ruffians,
We both decided to breathe in!
Why?
I take it every minute.
Yeah, very last minute.
I kid to you.
Can you tell what happened?
It wasn't math, but it's okay.
It wasn't.
You know what?
We had to do a passing!
Yeah.
So, but if we had given up then... It wouldn't happen.
Right?
Exactly, we passed.
So, you know, just believe in yourself.
Don't be nervous.
Just do your best, okay?
Do your best.
You can do it.
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions today.
We'd like you to remember that FUWAMOCO Morning is something that we make all together with you, Ruffians.
So if you have any doggy of the days or questions, you know, those kind of things, please submit them to us with the hashtag, hashtag FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
Next!
What do we have for our next stream?
It's a Monday.
It's the start of the week.
But... De-den!
We have... De-den!
This time, it's the end.
Yeah, we're gonna do our best to get past these last few levels.
They're very, very tricky, very difficult.
Very different from the rest of the game, huh?
Yeah.
It's called Very Very Very Chicken now.
But I think, you know, there's two of us!
Yeah!
Through cooperation together.
And me taking your controller.
I think we can do it.
We can become the strongest duo ever, right?
Right!
Please help us, Ruffians.
We're really gonna need your help, okay?
We are!
We need to do this!
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, we're gonna take down the dude.
BAU BAU!
And our schedule!
Well, we have a very exciting week.
There's a lot coming up.
A lot of spookiness.
And you know, if you notice, even though FUWAMOCO Morning on a Friday is... Well, it's October Friday the 13th, right?
So you can never be too sure what will happen.
You have to be there, Ruffians!
I guess.
Thank you.
Thank you, Ruffians, for joining us today for the 30th FUWAMOCO Morning.
Thank you, and hopefully we'll be able to enjoy many, many more FUWAMOCO Mornings all together.
Would you like that?
I hope you like that.
Because that's the plan.
That's the plan!
But before we say BAU BAU for that, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today.
Matt!
BAU BAU!
Hidori L!
TaitoKaizu!
BAU BAU!
Ooty.
Swimming pools.
BAU BAU!
Radiant JP.
Bright Summer.
BAU BAU!
June.
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!